the house passing a coronavirus relief
bill at 1:00 a.m. Saturday morning after
drawn-out negotiations between Speaker
Nancy Pelosi and Treasury secretary
Steve minuchin the president is expected
to sign the deal but first it has to
pass through the Senate a senior
Republican source telling Fox not to
underestimate the challenge the bill
could face in the Senate and with that
let's bring in our headliner he is Texas
congressman Michael McCall he's ranking
member of the House Foreign Affairs
Committee congressman thanks for coming
in you voted for this package in the wee
hours Saturday morning there were a lot
of your Republican colleagues in the
house who were not happy that they were
handed it at the last minute they didn't
like some of the spending in there they
did they there's some confusion in fact
there we're told there may be some
technical Corrections because it was
passed with such haste if there's some
trouble in the Senate what next sir well
look we're in a crisis there's no doubt
about that we need to move quickly on
this I don't think we have the luxury of
time I you know I had the same concerns
you know it was it was a thrown together
I will say the version Nancy Pelosi
dropped you know the night that the
Rules Committee versus what we voted on
the floor changed dramatically and
that's primarily because secretary
minutiae and the White House were able
to negotiate a far better bill on this
on this issue I think primarily what it
does ed as it gets testing out to
everyone in America who needs it free of
cost we're getting ready to move in to
the next two months which will get worse
not better we're moving from containment
now to community spread illness this is
not a time to to to wait around I think
we need action right now from the
Congress this provides the unemployment
insurance and it provides school meals
to kids who can't go to school I think
the social distancing though factor if I
could say is probably the most important
element we need to talk about to try to
keep what what dr. of the NIH talked
about and that was keeping this this
curve more flat the next two months are
going to be critical
what this disease is what we saw at
South Korea in Italy two different
models we want to follow the South Korea
model more testing out there and flatten
this curve so we don't have cases
increase exponentially whether it comes
to the testing congressman or the
changes to travel of course the
president's European travel ban now
taking an effect but over the weekend we
saw those crowds of people you talk
about the social distancing how
important it is but yet then you saw our
airports flooded with people in massive
crowds sometimes standing in line for
hours so are we deploying these these
tactics are we deploying these
strategies in the best way possible well
I think we can do better and I talked to
CVP and Department of Homeland Security
I chaired the committee for three terms
for six years and and you know DFW my
home state was a nightmare and they're
coming in from out of country they have
to go through the screening the medical
screening and they're waiting in lines
for hours with thousands of people talk
about a we're talking about social
distancing and the NIH CDC is talking
about this and yet you've got hordes of
the people being held up in lines that
our airports literally like a petri dish
of that that has to be corrected I think
it will be I think they're going to put
more people in overtime and bring new
screeners in medical screeners to get
that process moving far more quickly
than it is congressmen used to be the
chair of the Homeland Security Committee
and I wonder as well to add another
element to when you see that kind of
chaos at airports the federal government
focused rightly so on this health crisis
how concerned are you about bad actors
around the world trying to take
advantage of the United States at a
moment like this well that's why you
know I don't think the president's
getting enough credit for shutting down
people coming in from China right out of
the box he said all foreign nationals
from China cannot come in to the United
States now Americans were in a different
position he also a screen passengers
from South Korea Italy and now travel
ban on Europe these are all very
aggressive tactics but they are tactics
necessary to protect the American people
from actors
coming in whether it be somebody not
knowing they have the virus versus
people knowing they have it and also we
always look at bioterrorism
this is always an issue whether it be at
the border not too far from where I'm
sitting here today we have to stop this
virus we have to contain it from coming
in the United States now that it's here
we get a flat net curve and make sure it
doesn't spread to more and more
Americans again the next two months are
critical and then I think as we move
into the summer
you're gonna see it phasing down of
cases that's where we want to be by
summer well we are as good as the
forecast that can be out there right now
we just don't know what is happening
next with all this but we can look at
markets this morning congressman and you
saw that another trading halt had to
happen because circuit breakers were
triggered you've got the Dowell off 9.4%
it's another big sell-off on Wall Street
and this as we all try to measure the
economic impact of this virus and fears
of this virus on our economy senator
senator Marsha Blackburn was on Fox and
Friends over the we sorry on Fox who
said oh she was on Fox and Friends
yesterday she was talking about what can
be done to mitigate the economic impact
what we have to do is think about the
entire supply chain you know you all
were just talking about the cruise lines
well what about the dock workers what
about the entertainers or the speakers
that have lost their bookings on those
cruises and I've had several in
Nashville who have called and have asked
me about this they don't want the burden
to end up on small business and this is
something that we're going to look at
you're fielding similar questions as
well Congress and what more can be done
on that front well you know I agree I
think the markets are there's a lot of
uncertainty obviously in their
responding very negatively I will tell
you talking to people like Larry Kudlow
that the fundamentals in our economy are
still very strong that's why we're gonna
get through this thing but it is gonna
have an impact on the market so I worry
about both entertainment Marsha talked
about but also the airlines are talking
about possibly going into
bankruptcy by May I think if I can say
there are two more positive things that
have come out recently that I hope will
give the markets more reassurance one
are there antivirals three of them now
being tested in China on Chinese of
patients that have shown great promise
so we're getting your report in April
next month about that and the the first
clinical trial vaccine is being tested
today in Seattle Washington will still
take about a year to finalize that but
that's actually some positive news we
have to reassure the markets that this
thing is not gonna spiral out of control
that's why that bill is so important to
pass because it will give certainty than
markets and it will provide testing that
we desperately need throughout the
United States yeah so congressman the
the bill you're talking about that it's
in the Senate's hands now may be phase
one and all of this others have said
it's phase two because there was about
eight billion dollars spent the previous
week last question then what do you
foresee in terms of how many more phases
we may have in terms of helping the
airlines helping hotels helping the
cruise industry
yeah I'm not normally a fan of bailouts
I voted against the bailout no back in
the crisis back then but I will say we
were gonna have to you know we did pass
eight billion for research for
treatments in the vaccine the last bills
for families first to make sure we get
the screening we get paid sick leave
things that everyday Americans are
worried about and I think there will be
a third tranche coming out to deal with
industry you know these the the the tax
cuts that we are talking about that we
want to provide to to people at middle
to low income on their payroll tax so
that they can keep them more of what
they earn and put back in the economy
our fundamentals are strong and I think
that is important too to say this is a
bit of a curveball coming outside from
Wuhan China and Marsh is right about
supply chain economics we got to get out
the supply chain of China it's not good
for the United States a lot to be
certified yeah a lot of big issues and
the health crisis is first and foremost
that's what a lot of people are
grappling with we appreciate you coming
in this more
sir Thank You congressman they said